i've not listened to this
let's listen to it together and and see
what it what it's about
david jimmy from philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired
and listen to your [ __ ] about
unhinged trump supporters and this and
that
you're so full of [ __ ] i i got
my hat's off to you you can't you you
you can't withstand it david yeah my
information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
flippy from indiana flippy from indiana
please unmute you
are on the air my friend all right can
you hear me yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making an only fans
uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely
i'd be more likely to show my my granny
smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh
five and a quarter
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man cameron tv
person woman man camera
tv
that's amazing how did you do that
that's amazing
okay memory
yeah exactly okay so we're back um it is
a very very important stream today we
are going to be hearing not only from uh
biden white house press secretary jen
saki but also from former secretary of
state and current
i think what is it like environmental
cesar
john kerry as well as gina mccarthy
so it's going to be a pretty big um
it's going to be a pretty big stream and
we already have
uh wow we already have a lot of people
getting banned on twitch that's crazy
um geez it's kind of sad but
i'll adjudicate those momentarily i also
have a bunch of
voicemails graffiti to show you guys
i want to say thank you to artistic
simplicity for the 17 months subscribed
on twitch
also milo wild for subscribing on twitch
and um also a big thank you
to israel merrill israel merrill just
signed up at joinpackman.com
denver mccarthy says that we got very
good marks on the new loading screen
yeah aj combist
david pakman show viewer um aj kambis
did the new
loading screen let me see if i can put
it up
okay anyway so that's pretty cool we
like that
and um yeah so twitch sent out a big
email really really powerful email
saying they've identified
it was some cartoonish number hold on
let me see if i can even find it
twitch.tv and
view messages where is this
our plan for addressing nope that's not
it
stream summary oh i can't it was like
11 million i don't even know it was some
crazy number of
of fake and bot accounts that twitch has
identified
and we lost like 40 subscribers when
that happened 40 followers on twitch
which suggests that most of our
followers are real which is just a good
thing
to to know pepe xanadu says via super
chat
is harsh reality for environmental
change that government people in power
only care about money since they're old
and will die
soon no i i believe john kerry really
cares about the environment
um i have no reason to doubt that jacob
says after reading confused or
ill-informed comments from the right on
youtube or voicemail do you think making
basic government 101
video would be worthwhile i don't know
i don't know that me doing that video i
think teaching it when kids are 11 would
be worthwhile i don't know if i'm going
to be able to save everybody
oh okafor says hey david hope all is
well what are your thoughts on
gala apples they're okay i think for a
pie
which i don't even eat apple pie but if
you were to if you insist on eating
apple pie
or if you want maybe uh like an of like
a
red wine oven roasted apple
baked apple i think a gala apple would
be fine
but the only apples i'm eating as an
apple
is a uh it's a granny smith that's just
that's where i
am from the standpoint of apples that's
all it is
okay everybody all right uh tucker
carlson
has done this maniacal laughter several
nights in a row now
i don't know how many of you saw this
but take a look at this
i'm kind of more worried about the rest
of the country which thanks to police in
action
in case you haven't noticed is like
boarded up
so that's more of my concern but i
appreciate it ed gavin thank you
nope done thank you or you're being
replaced and there's nothing you can do
about it
so shut up
isn't that something um i actually think
what's going
on and we're covering this on the show
today tucker
did this really weird segment earlier in
the week maybe i can even find it
where he was like oh jeff bezos is
digging around in my yearbook
and it's now been uncovered that tucker
um
said in high school or in college that
he was a fan of the guy who murdered
harvey milk for being gay
like it's not looking very good this is
the segment the world of big tech we
spent the day hearing from quite a few
old college classmates in some cases by
the way
he he uses the royal we like when i on
the show say we are doing something
i really mean like we as a team are
hiring someone for example
when tucker says we spent we we heard
spent the day hearing from classmates
they're only his classmates who's the we
his producers are getting calls from
classmates it's tucker
there's people we've been out of touch
with for 30 years people we've been out
of touch with but here's the occasion
for it
jeff bezos his 30-year 30 year old
producer has been out of touch with his
classmates for 30 years
at one of his minions a mentally
unbalanced middle-aged man called eric
wempel
pull our dusty college yearbook and call
around to see if we've done anything
naughty at the age of 19. that sounds
like fun let us know if you hear any
good stories
let us know bezos drops any more of his
billions on opposition research he
should know that it will not affect
any election outcome this is a news show
it's not a political campaign
he's not even telling us what this is
about no one here is running for
anything or plans to
on the other hand if jeff bezos wants to
come over to reminisce about 1987 on
this show
he's always welcome anytime okay so
anyway
then it turned out in his yearbook uh in
1991
tucker said he was a fan he was like
part of the dan white society dan
white's the guy who killed harvey milk
for being gay
and uh then my friend jeremy hooper
uncovered a 1990 op-ed
where tucker goes on a homophobic rant
it's like listen you could just say your
views were stupid and you changed them
if you did
but it just all is bizarre very very
strange
and i don't know i don't know what else
will come of it but that's tucker
and maybe that's what the point is maybe
that's why
he's behaving like this as to the
country which
thanks to police in action in case you
haven't noticed is like
boarded up so that's more of my concern
but i appreciate you coming on ed gavin
thank you
nope done thank you or you're being
replaced
there's nothing you can do about it so
shut up
it remind you know the first movie i
watched when my family moved to the
united states i remember we went and we
got a vhs in 1989
in 1990 whenever it was and the first
movie we rented was the 1989 batman with
jack nicholson and michael keaton
tremendous movie i mean like really high
marks
and i went to um uh i when we went to
blockbuster
i said to my parents let's rent this one
and they came to me and they said sir
are you sure you want this movie and i
said yes
the laugh reminds me of jack nicholson's
joker
in the 1989 batman
okay let's move on uh oh oh i'm sorry
big thank you to snuggles for gifting
five subscriptions
new grangler for gifting a sixth
as well as david chadman for 19 months
subscribed that's number seven canned
caviar gifted one
margot cabot subscribed that's nine
and uh wait a second nine plus three
nine plus three is twelve that's two
carry the one
one plus zero is one
putting us at 12 today and
uh the coop guys come on the coupon code
the coupon code's working the coupon
code's working
better 21 is the published coupon code
immoral 21 unpublished but
legal completely legal
okay free blue chew by the way every
10th subscription
i feel like that laugh is tucker making
fun of rachel maddow
that would be pretty meta i don't know
tucker says he's a news show fox
attorneys have argued he's not maybe
this can be used in future litigation i
mentioned that yesterday
yeah sounds like republican media is
going through stockholm syndrome for
trump and maga
to some degree to some degree oh okay
i have two twitch unban requests to
adjudicate
i have my gavel twitch has a mechanism
where if you are
unlucky enough or disgusting and
depraved enough to get banned you can
appeal
it uh on my last stream a
user showed up their only message
ever on the channel was david pakman in
the triple jewish parenthesis
they were banned their unbanned request
is simply i'm jewish
it's too stupid guys we just don't have
time for that nonsense so that is going
to be denied
and that is permaban
there is that one next unbanned request
is a user named the black swan
gamer they showed up and
said f you david packman you dick
that message was held they then came
immediately back and said f you david
pakman you dick
they were banned and their unbanned
request
is you david pakman you dick
that is a denial and
confirm and we are adjudicated
uh fully and now we can move on to other
things
okay so that is that
um what else did i have
so this is actually that i'm actually
kind of getting interested in this
my last name is starting to be
graffitied
all over the country now as i said
before i know that i believe it's in the
filipino community
pacman but pronounced pac-man but
spelled like my last name
i guess is a common nickname among
filipino people
i don't know culturally anything about
it so i'm not saying that all of these
are related to me
but viewers are starting to send me
elements of graffiti with my name from
across the country let me see if i can
put some of these up for you here
i think that this is something we should
investigate and also i would never
recommend anyone do anything
illegal but let's just say that if
people do this it'll probably get you on
the show if you can tell us exactly
where it is where people can go in
geocache
it's even better okay here is one i
don't i think this one's in
ohio or something like that it's like on
a curb someone wrote my last name
all right kind of interesting this one i
believe is in oakland
this one says pacman what and what else
is
here uh let's see what else is here
abe aid abe 2019
aca all cops are bastards uh oh
and then one last heaven
i don't i'm having a feeling that this
one doesn't relate to me i don't know
why
okay so that one's in oakland california
and then here's one
scene on a highway overpass and this one
almost looks like it's just written in
sharpie
like this one's not even that
artistically done
um and i don't even know where this one
is
i think actually noog frangler posted
this one to the subreddit and i don't
know if we know the location of it but
it was seen
on a highway overpass pass
oh noog is saying that all of them are
from oakland
i took photos of two of those oh
interesting
um you know what would be great newg if
you can get in touch and tell me
the exact address or how we could find
these in google maps it would be
compelling
if i could actually pull these up in
google maps and then we could even
direct
people to them uh maybe to do even like
a confirmation of that
okay alan lewis is i believe pac-man is
a nickname for manny pacquiao filipinos
use a k for most spelling so it gets
turned into pac-man
oh that's less interesting that's not
that cool
steven says we should offer a psych
referral to banned users
eugene says the thud of the gavel is not
absurd enough
better batman movie batman returns
versus dark knight
wait is batman returns the one with
danny devito
batman returns
1992 ooh that is tough
batman returns or dark knight dark
knight is good
i don't want to just pick the older one
because they saw it first kind of like a
conservative that would be really lame
um i think the devito one is probably
better
yeah no i would get an even bigger
i would get an even bigger gavel like it
might be funny to have one that's
too big to even bare like it'll barely
even fit on screen i would do that this
is the one that i found
okay let's continue as we stand
by here for gen saki i want to say
thank you to the sugar family for the
new membership at joinpackman.com
the sugar family did something really
bad actually
the sugar family signed up with the
coupon code immoral 21
but it also like the family that could
be four people using one membership
which seems
borderline illegal really every person
even children should have their own
memberships but
i still appreciate it i do i have some
new characters to introduce you guys to
via voicemail um let me see
here oh god i don't even know where to
start
i have five more voicemails from the
anti-trans woman who actually might be
trans we figured out
let's just start going through this here
is a new
anti-vaxx caller
hey what gives you the right to call
people that don't want to give a covered
shot
ignorant well the ask them why they're
not getting it their explanations are
ignorant
this is one of the i've explained before
that right now we have a tragedy in
american culture and society
where people don't understand what are
facts
now unders be i'm i'm wording that in a
very specific way
i'm not saying people don't understand
what the facts are
okay what i'm saying is people don't
understand what
type of statement counts as a fact
versus what is an opinion
so when he says what gives me the right
to say people are ignorant like for
example if they think that the vaccine
is microchipped
it's because they're wrong so it's an
ignorant statement that's what gives me
the right and by the way
rights who needs it that doesn't i don't
need you to give me the right
to explain that you're an ignorant
[ __ ] you little creeper
yeah you know i don't know where you can
come off on a [ __ ] national
television show
start your own show bro and then [ __ ]
cut people down like that because they
don't believe in what you do
it's not about it's about accepting
reality
you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you little
[ __ ] yeah i'm okay there we go
so that's anti-vaxx then i have
um fringe
neo-lib oh sorry before i i
i realize i'm not thanking some people
thanks to gordon z
hall for the twitch sub thanks to a
weissner
for the twitch sub thanks to vaderet
for the sub that's three milo gifted
five
which is eight crimson elric is nine and
wants sam
harris back on the show poo stain pete
has gifted five
and that's the only reason i'm saying
their name that puts us at 14
newg frankler has gifted a 15th
and i think that that's it 15 plus 13 is
28. okay
here's another one take a listen these
are all new callers
by the way oh let me explain what's
going on over the last
uh week the youtube channel
it popped it burst and
um we've had i want to say uh let me see
here
one two three four five six uh dozens of
clips
in the 200 000 view mark so when this
happens tons of new viewers come in many
of them
are disgusting people and then they
leave voicemail so that's why i have
like four new
voicemail callers to introduce today hey
david you uh
you quote these poll numbers
like you honestly believe the numbers
and the polls like it's not all rigged
why can't they just fake the poll
numbers are you that stupid
well bring me evidence they were faked
you can't be that stupid you've got to
be a
russian agent right that's all i've
come to
be convinced of teddy forever baby all
the way
wait what was that i've come to
be convinced of teddy forever baby all
the way oh teddy stratford one of our
that's weird this guy hates me but likes
our t our our shirt sponsor
[ __ ] neolib
okay so that's um that's a new caller
here's one caller another new caller who
i guess hates everyone
yeah i'm here just to say y'all are all
caught separate
uh democrat the like uh all of y'all are
[ __ ] liars
i see right through y'all's a little
precise here you you're going back and
forth like a bunch of little [ __ ]
cheese rolls over a piece of candy
and uh neither one wants to admit any
type of guilt
you're all [ __ ] guilty why don't you
just shut your
[ __ ] mouth and get it over with
whatever you want to do just [ __ ] do
it
quit playing you got doing games nobody
wants to hear this [ __ ] anymore
i guarantee you come to my house is
anyone like i just had my hearing tested
now this is not a joke the audiologist
actually said i tested all the way down
as low as she could even go
with the machine i reached the limit my
my hearing was just tested and it's fine
this collar sounds muddled doesn't it
sound like a muddy a muddy audio or is
that just me
oh that'll [ __ ] blow your head off
that was clear
but
they're still on the phone
all right okay the half the voicemail
was silence
all right so there's guy who hates
everyone now
do you guys want for jimmy from philly
furious voicemails because he can't
figure out the phone system that's gold
or do you want five voicemails from the
tran
anti-trans woman who maybe is trans
actually
and is sadly attacking trans people for
some reason
what do people prefer first no but i can
do a boat
people seem to want jimmy
okay let's go to jimmy this is jimmy
furious about the new phone discord
system it's crazy
baby give me some philly what why have
you made it so [ __ ] difficult to call
you
why can't i just call a [ __ ] phone
number this discord [ __ ] is [ __ ]
ridiculous
all right jimmy continuing to try to
figure out the discord system
david give me some philly [ __ ] the
contact form why have you made it so
difficult to contact you
i went on to discord it's it's [ __ ]
chinese and rhythm pick
why don't you make it to you why have
you made it difficult for people
to contact you a simple [ __ ] phone
number is all that's required
[ __ ] this [ __ ] okay then jimmy calling
back again
david kim from philly was why do you
make it so [ __ ] difficult to contact
you
right it's discord [ __ ] it's not
self-explanatory
apparently you have to have [ __ ] uh
uh um [ __ ] god i guess you have to
have discord installed
you're so [ __ ] mad if someone's gonna
call you how about just to [ __ ] phone
them
all right and then here's jimmy's last
one
from chloe white goddamn david leave it
to you
to complicate a simple act of calling in
i gotta hand it to you david you're an
[ __ ]
okay uh so there's jimmy unable able to
leave me four voicemails
but unable to i guess call in via
discord it's weird um
[Music]
okay and then lastly here is anti-trans
woman
just relentlessly calling all the time
endlessly you know what i just saw on
youtube
i saw someone becoming a man and at
first
when i you saw bar mitzvah oh wow that's
interesting i didn't know there were bar
mitzvah videos on youtube that's
i would like to see that i saw it i felt
that it was a boy
trying to be a woman because that was
more believable to me
that it was somebody who thought they
were a woman not crystal clear
and then they were like saying like
i'm a woman and this is my transition
into men and i'm thinking like
trying to look for a woman and i was
like are you guys understanding this
i'm still not seeing a difference like
i'm singing more of like a man
but it was totally believed more
believable when i looked at him her
to believe all right so this person is
just they they really have an issue
i actually think this is a repre it's
actually sad i believe this is a
repressed
trans person because in one voicemail
she confided
when i was growing up people thought i
was a boy
and i think there's a lot here
a girl who puts on who changes her
gender
for another woman does not like women
a woman a girl who changes her gender
for another
women does not like woman what the hell
if you're
saying like maybe women sometimes look
like
boys i'm not saying anything you don't
like women
you don't care about women and you don't
give a [ __ ]
and you want somebody else who maybe
looks like
a boy like why is this about me like
this has nothing to do with me
i'm with a woman who looks like a woman
and i this this isn't per
it may be hard for her to imagine that
my opinion on this might not be informed
by like my personal preference it's not
like i'm one of these anti-gay
nut republicans where suddenly my
nephew's gay and i'm like oh let's
actually get
gay people okay this isn't about me
might be hard for her to imagine that
i was just wondering what's going to
happen if one of your girls
ends up being somebody who
girls what are you talking about the
[ __ ]
i mean is it just that it's not that big
of a difference
of a jump from like your big nose
genetics
oh now it's getting anti-semitic now she
goes into big nose genetics oh boy um
yeah uh i think if i think if i had a
daughter
uh she wouldn't have my nose in fact my
little sister looks a lot like me she
has
she has a completely fine version of my
nose it translates beautifully to women
and and of course of course we were
waiting for the anti-semitism
of course we were waiting for it
there was like this spanish chick where
i lived in vermont and
a spanish chick um she kept crying about
like discrimination or something
she was crying about discrimination or
something and
she would say stuff like oh my god
they're treating me like i'm black or
like i'm italian or something like that
and she was like this really bossy like
mean [ __ ]
and she would always like cry about
discrimination and be like they're
treating me really badly and all this
kind of stuff
and i'm just like i'm sorry but like you
just fit in with the white trash
wow all right last one this caller may
be banned i think we're done with this
caller it's
this is the last one and i think she's
probably banned after this
i just feel like for a lot of mothers um
having a transsexual kid oh god okay and
we're done
all right let me just delete these five
and then we can just move on from that
um okay done and done
uh okay um oh
i've been sent one of the
locations of one of the pacman graffiti
elements this is 3501
harrison street in oakland california
where is it hold on a second oh there it
is
look at that there it is so this is an
overpass
i i hope that my the graffiti with my
name is in a nice place okay a couple
gas stations that's not bad
what are the prices here at this point
389 oh this must be old i think
gas in california is way more now uh 339
honestly i have no idea what gas costs
now i've had an electric car for a while
is the are these current gas prices does
anyone know
i thought it was like five bucks a
gallon in california
no one knows the gas prices okay perfect
cool if i hit the clock in the upper
left
oh okay february 2020
february 2020. okay very good so if you
want to travel to this overpass this
maybe will become a new
gathering place like maybe viewers can
even gather to watch live streams
here we it says my last name
my recommendation is if it's safe maybe
on this sidewalk
take a picture of yourself with the
graffiti that would
definitely make it onto the show by the
way
look at this oddly placed street light
i've never seen
what is it what is powering it it almost
looks drawn on
that is strange i've never it's just
stuck into the the concrete
wow wow urban exploration really
happening here
i don't know guys i think this might be
the the graffiti artist right here
his face being blurred is suspicious to
me
i'm kidding by the way oh look at this
dollar 79 hot dog
is that with cheese that's not even bad
actually i mean
if it's all beef i would look at that
okay we're standing by for jen
saki she will be briefing us with john
kerry
as well as with gina mccarthy and i'm
actually very interested
interested in what's going to be said
here okay so let's
let's stand by for that um pepe xanadu
says do you think chauvin will try to
end his life before
sentencing he's on suicide watch so i
don't think he'll succeed
have i thought about minting any nft art
for the show
you know drew i have i would be willing
to do
some nft stuff with some original show
things like some of the
for example i have an original picture
of me and former producer lewis in the
old old old studio
i would be open to the idea of of uh
tokenizing that nft from the standpoint
of
elements of nft and making that
available
i just don't actually know how to do it
i would need someone to get in touch and
to be like here i can consult with you
here's how you nft
that picture that original and um
i think it's a great idea okay somebody
help me do it miscellaneous user says
use a squawking rubber chicken for
permabans
pedro says how all the deranged
voicemails add to the stream
i don't you tell me if they don't i
won't do it anymore
noldo says david you should spend less
time caring about how many new followers
you have it's like 50
of your time i don't think i've even
mentioned followers i'm thanking people
who are
signing up and supporting financially
because i think it's the polite thing to
do
um like for example calvin bourne just
signed up
blake a stone says listen here david
four months subbed and you don't even
bonk the gavel all right i can do that
thank you to blake a stone for four
months
there it is zak prakowski has subbed
zachary has subbed krelix dr
dongstrong has subbed dub dab
is number seven 28 plus seven is 35.
um
someone wants me to confirm that the the
secret coupon code works
it it works every once in a while i try
it and it doesn't okay let's try it
sign up coupon code
immoral 21
there it is dollar 86 it works perfectly
works perfectly absolutely no issue
whatsoever did you see the destiny wolf
debate last night
you know i tuned in to the richer as
many of you know richard wolff was my um
college one of my college economics
professors
uh oh but yeah that's true this guy
donated to complain about donations
being acknowledged but wanted his
donation being
to be acknowledged okay i saw the
richard wolf
destiny thing i saw about 20 minutes
yesterday the 20 minutes i saw
were only about them arguing how they
would define
socialism and capitalism in order to be
able to start the debate
and then i bailed and i went to work out
it's like how long am i going to just
see a debate about what is
socialism and capitalism um
so i didn't and i you know i was joking
around in the comments some people were
were mixing it up i said something like
uh would someone be able to give us a
list of 10 to 12 examples
of things that are not feudalist just to
like really
set the context um
maybe i'll check it out you know um
but yeah it wasn't i mean i just i i
just don't have time in my day
to watch like a three hour debate i just
don't and i know that there's people who
get mad when i say it and they say david
more
long form and this and that between the
show and different things it's like i
want to be working out
we're dealing with tech issues that i
was dealing with yesterday
we've got um you know i have books that
i want to be reading
okay you know that's it that's it i
can't put it on 1.5 x speed if it's live
do you check to see if a coupon code is
working to encourage people how to sign
up seems like a strategy no
it's genuinely people are saying david
the coupon code really isn't working
although it's not a bad strategy now
that you mention it
um oh here we go
oh let's go to the white house feed i
prefer the white house feed
it's slightly behind but we see video of
the journalists
which we love oh thanks to chas
baird chaz baird just signed up on my
website new member number 36
hi everyone okay here we go
[Music]
okay
happy earth day everyone uh and joining
us in the briefing room for the second
time
i told you they'd come back and take
more questions i deliver on my promises
is national climate advisor gina
mccarthy and special presidential envoy
for climate
john kerry we're of course very excited
to have them here after their short
remarks they will be able to take just a
few questions because they have a busy
climate summit underway with that i will
turn it over to
gina mccarthy
thanks jen and thanks everybody it's
great to be here i'm
happy earth day uh on day one
president biden fulfilled his promise to
rejoin the paris
agreement and as part of reentering the
paris agreement was she from boston
the whole of government process that was
organized through his climate task force
to establish the 2030 emissions target
which is
known as the nationally determined
contribution or ndc
and it's a formal submission to the
united nations um
under the united nations framework
convention on climate change
the ndc is is a commitment and it's
and our end people reacting to that he
says that the united states will reduce
our net economy-wide greenhouse gas
emissions by
50 to 52 percent below
2005 levels by 2030.
in this target bills on u.s leadership
at all levels of government i love this
woman this is great dates and positions
american workers in industry to help us
tackle the climate crisis
today's announcement is a product of
this government-wide
assessment on how to make the most of
the opportunity
of combating climate change and what it
presents for us
and our future to get here we went
sector by sector
electricity transportation building
industry and lands and oceans and we
looked at the wealth of
already existing cost-effective clean
technologies and products
that are ready for deployment and
innovation trends
that we see in the marketplace that will
allow us to win the clean energy future
and the opportunities we now have to
create good
paying union jobs improve public health
keep our communities safe and advance
environmental justice over the past
nearly 100 years of this administer
i'm sorry 100 days feels like he is at
times
uh 100 days of this administration
we met with and listened to cities and
states businesses
workers scientists economists young
people parents
grandparents like me who were actually
around
during the first earth day and hope to
be around for quite a few more
the output of the the bottom-up analysis
and robust engagement is this
and that is that we see multiple
pathways
across all sectors across all policy
levels
across federal and state and local
actions
to grow our economy and to reduce our
emissions
look president biden has always believed
that tackling the climate crisis
presents a valuable economic opportunity
absolutely
the fact is creating jobs and tackling
climate
change go hand in hand we invest
in the competitiveness of our industry
and
empower us workers to build more
resilient and sustainable infrastructure
and propel us
that is how we lead and move forward in
manufacturing and exports of clean
energy technologies
in some ways for my team every day since
january 20th
has been earth day and jobs day
every week has been infrastructure week
and innovation week
we've marshaled the whole of government
the fantastic cabinet
and the remarkable team of climate and
clean energy experts across the federal
government
behind this president's vision not just
to develop the target
but to unlock the opportunity that
achieving this target represents
because when president biden hears
climate he thinks
jobs and it's no wonder the work we need
to do is
is not just about avoiding an
existential threat
which climate change is it's about how
we create
jobs for line workers building thousands
of miles she's wicked smart
for a clean mod and resilient grid
workers in energy communities capping
abandoned wells
and reclaiming mines and stopping
methane leaks
it's about auto workers building modern
efficient electric vehicles
and charging infrastructure to support
them you can follow me right after this
briefing if you want to go hang out at
union station
you can get a close look at ev
infrastructure in action
i like that and engineers and
construction workers expanding carbon
capture and green hydrogen
to forge cleaner steel and cement it's
about farmers
using cutting edge tools to make
american soil
the next frontier of carbon innovation
so let's be clear the american jobs plan
will help us more fully tap
the economic upside here investing in
infrastructure innovation in our workers
and communities
it's something we cannot afford to pass
on
let me close by reiterating what brings
me here to work every day
especially at this moment in my career
it's joe biden's unwavering
focus on people on the ear they breathe
and on their health on the strength of
their communities
and environmental justice on the dignity
that comes with good work and jobs we
can create
on how we keep working together and move
beyond a year
we all would love to put behind us
to one of renewed hope and opportunity
because after all
this day is all about investing in
america and winning the future for our
children
that's why we're here earth day jobs day
every day thank you and now let me pass
it on to my good friend and my fellow
bostonian
secretary john kerry thank you
man this is the best briefing
she's from dorchester thank you very
much gina i'm i'm
really happy to be here to share this
day
and the subject matter is way too tall
for the microphone and i want to
begin by uh just sharing with you what a
spectacular job
gina and her team have done you may
remember the executive order which said
the president
will aim to announce the ndc at the
summit
uh the aim was not that he had any
question about wanting to do that the
aim was
whether or not gina or anybody could
pull together
all the parties that had to be part
of preparing an ndc a gigantic
administrative organizational task
which gina and her entire team have done
really superbly
and i mean that that's not a pro-forma
comment it is hard
to get all of the disparate elements of
your government together the president
by issuing his executive order to make
this the climate issue
and all of government enterprise and
instructing every single cabinet officer
and every single agency officer
to comprehensively factor
climate consequences into every decision
that they were making
as they should and they have done that
and gina created this task force we've
never had an all of government task
force on the subject
ever before we had it now because gina's
creation
and and it's worked and that's what
brought everybody together to get
this uh ambitious but appropriate
achievable goal in place so i
salute her and i thank her for that it's
a great service
and everywhere that i went in the world
uh in the course of the last months
first question out of people's mouths
was what's your ndc going to be what are
you guys going to do
you you've destroyed your credibility
you've left the paris agreement
uh how can we trust you right it's going
to happen
to which there is a very very powerful
answer change what is now happening
globally in the marketplace and that is
part of the message of what's happened
here today
and in the last few days you've had
yesterday we announced the net zero bank
alliance we announced the
the glasgow financial alliance for net
zero
and we have some 43 financial
institutions across the world worth some
i forget the exact sum inspiring
speakers some trillion dollars or
something in terms of assets managed
and just yesterday a number of banks
announced
six banks to be precise that they are
allocating
or setting or making a commitment that
they will invest
into climate related efforts
initiatives investments 4.16 trillion
dollars over the next 10 years that's
been a really missing element in all of
this
so i'm really happy to be here today for
a number of reasons first of all
uh just uh um parenthetically
uh five years ago today
i had my granddaughter on my knee in new
york and
signed the paris agreement and that was
a great moment for
everybody in the world when everybody
came together in new york excitedly
to set out on this venture
regrettably regrettably without any
facts without
regrettably without any facts without
any science without any
rationale we're on the live feed that's
not on
on my end just so people know president
decided to pull out he's the only
president in the entire world
the only chief of state in the entire
world
who without any scientific evidence
decided to pull out of the paris
agreement
so when president biden was elected
having made climate one of the most
critical issues of his agenda
we had a big step to get up
we had to restore america's credibility
we had to prove that we were serious
and i think today does that in many ways
and not in a chauvinistic
um in a way that that's sort of
inappropriate to our relationship with
other countries
but in a way that uh reinforces the fact
that this is multilateral that we need
to bring
all the countries of the world to the
table and we all need
to raise ambition that's the central
theme
of this meeting today we must all raise
ambition and you heard that in i thought
profoundly uh meaningful
moving understandably frustrated and
angry words
tame for anger uh words that came from
uh uh bastida
uh and and that's where a lot of the
younger generation is today
appropriately pretty upset at the adults
the alleged adults
who are not getting their act together
to make happen what needs to happen
right we aren't there yet either but
today we
built a huge foundational building block
in the effort
to get there so the importance of today
and my judgment is this the world came
together
president xi prime minister modi
president putin
presidents of small countries and big
countries
macro chancellor of germany the eu
itself independently
for people in the financial marketplace
and others
all of them in agreement that
this this is a crisis it is the climate
crisis
and it's going to require an enormous
lift to get where we need to go
so what happened today just to
underscore
where we are on january 19th we were
nowhere we were in deficit
with respect to our efforts morally
because of president biden's leadership
and calling a summit and putting us on
the line to do this
we now have about 55 of a global gdp
committed to levels of reductions
that keep faith withholding the earth's
temperature at 1.5 degrees that is a big
chunk of difference and
we've done that working with countries
sitting down with them
with japan with korea with australia
with
indonesia uh with uh
india with the middle east with 11
countries at one meeting where
even oil producing countries stepped up
and made things clear
and of course
china included
as well as some
latin american countries and african
countries so
i i'm pleased with where we are but with
many countries
the next six months of diplomacy are
going to be absolutely critical
to the capacity to make glasgow what it
needs to be
i do believe glasgow remains our last
best hope to be able to
coalesce the world in the right
direction and to get the critical mass
of countries of the 20
biggest emitters who are responsible for
81
of all the emissions all 20 of them were
here today
and almost all 20 of them were pledging
to do
additional things so that's our job is
to be to clarify it over the course of
these next weeks and months
i just clarified very quickly japan said
they'd cut emissions 46
to 50 percent uh by 2030
strong efforts towards achieving a 50
reduction up from existing 26
reduction canada strengthening
uh from a current 30 percent to a 40 to
45 percent
the republic of korea terminating
overseas coal finance
and preparing to update its ndc
consistent with the 2015 net zero goal
india a partnership with the united
states to deploy 450 gigawatts of
renewable power why is that important
because if we can do that which is where
our finance
component of this is so critical if we
do that
india is on track to hold the 1.5
degrees
centigrade so argentina announced a
package of important measures the big
package in argentina just to announce 78
target uh by 2035 and yesterday
eu announced new law to embed the 55
reduction for 2030 and also the net zero
so um you know i think that it's
progress
but we still have a heavy lift and no
one should
doubt the challenges of the road ahead
so happy to be here
all right i know we're very close to the
tail end of when gina has to go
so um let's try to get her yeah
go ahead thank you secretary of chariot
first when it comes to the pledge
how can you realistically make this
pledge to the rest of the world when
there's no guarantee
that republicans will get on board with
your plan
once you release it well a lot of the
plan
is executable uh through this executive
order i'm gonna let gina speak to this
but a lot of the plan is executable
through
order aka screw them having the private
sector here
that is the real reason why i'm saying
to you that no politician in the future
is going to do this because all over the
world
trillions of dollars trillions of yen
trillions of
euros are going to be heading into this
new marketplace quadrillions of
argentinian patients belongs
to the countries as you heard today from
any number of leaders
that are the ones who develop uh
hydrogen
green hydrogen fuel or storage or
battery storage or direct
carbon capture from the atmosphere some
technology is going to break through
here folks
and one of the things i know the
president's thinking about is
is how to accelerate the innovation and
the research and development that's
going to push that curve gina do you
want to talk to that a little bit
gina please talk about growing up in
dorchester uh just to indicate
to you that this is is really a result
of understanding what our authorities
are
at the federal government also what's
happening at the local and state level
what's happening in the business
community what kind of technologies that
that are ready to be deployed now
how many jobs can be created by this
this is not just a bottoms up it's also
a values
down it's also looking at how we grow as
a country and be sustainable
the the plan that the president has put
in place and the plan that we're relying
on here
is a plan that we can deliver because we
have the wherewithal to do it in terms
of policies and programs
but we also have carefully looked at
what we can deliver in terms of change
and the world is changing it's not going
backwards
it is moving forward and the exciting
thing about this
is that this plan has received
endorsements from the afl-cio the
chamber of commerce
the edison electrical institute and the
ibew
does it get better than that you know
this is because all of them recognize
that we have to invest in america again
that's what the american
jobs plan is all about that's what we
anticipate
our country will do because we know how
to make this happen
we can put people back to work and it's
time for us to think about hope and
opportunity
and get past the year that we're
finishing
isn't that the best so i just got a lot
of people that would say
stay here but a lot of people would say
you know
um if you haven't if the president
hadn't put the plan forward you'd be
asking why you haven't put the plan
forward to do
the building out of a transmission
system for america or whatever it is
he's put it forward and it's a
legitimate thing to say
now can it get passed can you get there
but uh uh
this is the this job future
is not something conjured up out of
anybody's imagination it's the most real
thing in the world
bureau of labor statistics says there
are three jobs that will actually grow
more than 50
this year the first is 62 growth
in wind turbine technician right the
second
is nurse practitioners for obvious and
unfortunate reasons and the third is
solar
panel installer at 51
so the jobs are growing there i'm not
offering that job to somebody who may
feel oh my god i got a better job i
don't want to lose that job etc
but the job market here is going to be
gigantic and for electricians plumbers
bite fitters steel
it's crazy that gina's six foot five how
tall does that make carry
out america's legit grid and
transitioning us to
this new future is is going to happen in
countries all over the world
we need to make sure we're not left
behind in fact that we're leading
in the creation of new technologies new
opportunities and
the only other thing i would i would
mention is that you know wind and solar
had the biggest year they've ever had
last year and and what we saw last year
was was
continuation of tax credits that passed
through a republican-controlled
congress so we all know where this is
heading
right the real question is do we want to
have the courage to grab it here
to prosper from the jobs here and to
stabilize
our economy and our planet at the same
time
[Music]
i'd love gina to tell us whether she's
holding doji coin
electric vehicles are another
interesting piece that's actually going
to be a big part of our future
i'm going to go check out as a charging
station and look at some of those
vehicles
but the thing i would encourage you to
think about is that
we've had many of the large car
companies stand up and say 100
evs by 2035. we didn't say that
i didn't even say electric vehicles it
was the very first thing they
said to me is that that's the future and
that's what this is all about
what does our future look like who are
we grabbing it for
uh happy earth day thank you thank you
i'll take a couple more okay all right
okay go ahead peter
secretary kerry thanks so much so
pledges obviously are important and they
are great but how do we realistically
get there without turning the economy on
its ear as best you can put this in real
terms for folks does this mean
the us has to reach 40 renewable power
by 2030 that we have to have 25 percent
of the cars on the roads
by 2030 be electric what does this mean
to folks
listening to you what it means is that
we're going to be investing this is not
an ex this is not a throwaway this is
investment
in new ways of getting energy to people
that's more efficiently delivered
it's lower cost in the long run um
and uh that it's it's really going to
open up a whole
group of employment opportunities that
we know
that are beginning to be seen in america
today and it's not because the
government's directing those things to
happen the marketplace is doing this
you can't build a coal-fired power plant
in the united states
with a bank funding it and no individual
is
going to throw the money down there same
thing in europe today
now starting in other countries you just
heard korea to say we're not going to
fund any external coal so there's a
transition that the market has
undertaken well before anybody proposed
a program or anything
this is a transition that's taking place
and we've historically
always gone through these periods when
in america we innovate
and we do the r d and we come up with a
new
product of some kind or another you know
i lived and represented for years the
privilege of representing communities
like lowell and lawrence and
brockton and plenty of places you know
fall river
that have these huge mills that were
you know teaming with people working in
the early 1900s and
then that changed and it went south in
our america in
our country and then it went abroad
because that's the transition in
economies
and it happened in the industrial
revolution it happened in the revolution
of technology in the 1990s
and it's going to happen now we
always replace it with a different kind
of or some
you know new opportunity and um
i don't think it's going to mean that
much dislocation frankly it's going to
mean
some greater opportunity what
specifically can you you probably can't
give specific numbers to those things on
electric vehicles on the road then but
given what you witnessed with the last
president what if president biden
is not to win again in 2024 what
specifically can you do now
to make sure that the next president
with us i'll answer that very directly
but i want to begin
by pointing out to you that uh there's a
company called tesla which is the
highest valued automobile company in the
world
why all it makes is one product electric
vehicles
arguably speculation is what is
happening that's a signal that's the
market
saying here we are this is going to
happen
and gm has now already announced
on its own that they are only going to
pelosi's scooping up options right now
and ford motor company asked the
president of ford i i heard him
at an event standing up and said oh
thanks to tyt for the raid by the way i
appreciate that guys welcome and and now
if you've dreamed one but they're
fabulous they're really great
and so my my very big on tesla
that this is going to take place because
the market is sending signals and the
consumer is sending signals now that
said how do you prevent somebody from
coming along
and preventing the stroke of the pen
change here's it here's what is going to
happen
no question about it because
the world as a whole is moving in this
direction
because these companies have made this
critical long-term strategic
marketing judgment and that is the way
the market's moving
no politician no matter how demagogic or
how potent capable they are is going to
be able to change what that market is
doing because it will have moved it'll
have four years of entrenchment
and those jobs will be there and people
will see that this
is the product people want to buy and
they will also
increasingly i believe
more and more convinced by the heat in
the summer by the floods by the
weather by the intensity of storms by
the rising of sea level
that we got to get moving and i don't
think anybody's going to get back from
that
fast because we're way behind the eight
ball on that
and the chances of seeing more damage
before we see the progress
is very very real can we do one or two
more
good job thanks jen secretary kerry
president
putin and um bolsonaro today
both through a little bit of shade at
the united states jeff mason follower of
the david pakman show in the room
i was wondering what's your take on
their plans and your response to those
criticisms and whether or not you have
an intention to to travel to those
countries
um well at some point probably uh travel
will be warranted
uh we've been in conversations with both
with their teams
on this subject we're not at a place
where we
feel like we're prepared to
you know make the journey because
there's a sense that there may be
something concrete that we can
define but i think there may be chances
of it i listened to president putin
today i thought he was
pretty rational and put some decent
visionary thoughts on about things we
might want to be looking at and
cooperating together and he talked about
that possibility
so just as with china where we found a
way to try to at least
create this chain this line of
communication
and where we have a long way to go but
but it's a beginning
and that's the nature of diplomacy but i
think that
uh i i i think that
uh we're in a place
where um we will have the ability
to be able to create enough
progress with other countries that
those countries are going to come along
too and
and i sense from both of them i i some
of the comments that president bolsonaro
made today surprised me for
their you know that that that that's
pretty good that works if you do those
things the question is will they do them
and the question is what's the
follow-through and enforcement now one
of the things you ought to take note of
is this program the trace program which
al gore and
different entities have been involved in
which is now the satellite capacity
to measure in real time what the
footprint is of corporations or
countries all around the world and and
so there's no hiding anymore
and and there's going to be real time
tracking
and that's one of the things that will
come out of glasgow i think is sort of
what's the
accountability structure going to be
here for countries to be able to move
so i think that uh you know russia has
reduced some emissions they
their economy is very different from
mars and a lot of people on the planet
it's mostly gas-based as we know that
presents challenges for them going
forward
so i think there's room to you kind of
get the sense john kerry knows
stuff which is a change if we can find
some common ground
i think that's the you know most
important
summary of what i heard in terms of
their comments today
the 52 that the president unveiled today
that gina mccarthy put together
is far enough for the us i think it's uh
it's doable uh it's a tough it's not
it's not easy uh is it doable
uh yes will we probably exceed it i
suspect yes
i think a lot of us will wind up
exceeding
the predictions we're making because
we're measuring predictions by the
economies we have today
and by the technologies we have today
but five years from now we may have a
major breakthrough on
batteries on storage on green hydrogen
and direct air carbon capture i actually
think that we are going to have major
breakthroughs on direct carbon capture
that are going to dramatically change
what's possible in terms of dealing with
these numbers investment
and venture capital business i mean
people are looking to
you know to be the the entity that that
hits
paydirt with the patent
on the best storage system that there is
and whoever does that will make more
money than jeff bezos pretty quickly
it's going to be a big deal green
hydrogen
a whole bunch of countries working on
hydrogen and green
and if you can bring it up to scale at a
cost
that is not prohibitive so you're
competitive with other things
it starts to take off i think these
things going to happen
i'll tell you i'm genuinely optimistic
because so much is beginning to happen
and because i believe in our ingenuity
and our capacity i know president biden
does i've heard him talk about it
he believes we can do anything you've
heard him say it
and and think about it we are the
country that went to the moon
and we didn't know how we were going to
get there when president kennedy
announced that goal but we did it
we are the country that invented the
internet some people might regret that
today
but but we did that we also
got vaccines that are working and we've
shown we have the ability to get them
out and put them in people's
arms so i believe that we have the
ability when
when you know you talk to rafael reef
president of mit and you listen to what
they're trying to do at mit or at
stanford or
cal tech or you know a number of other
tech colleges and universities in
america if we were to join forces as
we're going to try to with
other efforts around the world we think
there are just great opportunities
and i believe we're going to we're going
to break through we're going to know how
to do hydrogen
and there's plenty of it and and
this i think is is really the future
it's why so many people are chasing it
but i will also give you the contact
information for his team for anybody
wants to talk to him more
he's lots of thoughts as you all know go
ahead um kind of
piggybacking off of jeff's last question
you know there
there have been some groups that have
been really positive about the ndc and
the other
steps that the administration has taken
today the climate finance stuff
um but there are also some who are
saying it's insufficient
and uh if you reference the young woman
who spoke this morning
uh you know in that deep passion about
the crisis that previous generations
have
put on her generation what do you say to
those people who say
that 50 to 52 uh is
is not enough or that um you know the
several billion dollars that you're
committing
uh for climate finance for developing
countries is also insufficient
you know when you consider just how big
the u.s budget is and you're talking
about you know
under 10 billion dollars well let me
just say to you that uh
i loved her passion and
i loved what she said i mean i didn't
agree with every step of it you can't do
some of this stuff
overnight just physically
and there are impediments to getting
some of that done but boy do i
understand where she's coming from
i told you this was five years of the
day
that i signed the agreement it's also 50
years to the day that i testified before
the united states senate and
i was camped on the mall here with a
bunch of veterans
opposing the war in vietnam and
you know that was a period of time when
young people
our generation stood up and and
made our voices heard and we had we were
part of the civil rights movement
1964 65 we were part of the women's
movement part of the
peace movement part of the environment
movement the environment movement back
then
produced i was part of the first earth
day
and we organized i organized
massachusetts then we organized for the
election we targeted 12 congress people
who were labeled the dirty dozen the
worst of the congress
and we beat seven of them and that's
when we passed the clean air act
the safe drinking water act the marine
mammal protection the coastal zone
management the endangered species
and we created the environmental
protection agency for our country it all
happened folks back then richard nixon
signed it into law
1972 i think so um
i believe in what the young folks are
doing out there today they're trying to
get adults to be adults
and do what we're supposed to do which
is take facts into consideration
and respond to those facts and as public
officials exercise the precautionary
principle of governance
that when you get information that says
x y and z are gonna happen
and there's not a five or six or ten
percent chance it's going to happen like
whether you might have a car accident
you get insurance or your home might
burn and you get insurance or you
might get sick and you get health
insurance it's a hundred percent certain
that most of these things are going to
happen that the ice is melting the sea
is rising that
warming and yet we're not buying
insurance
and so you darn right there angry and i
share that anger it's
frustration but how do you get from here
to there to get it done
and i believe what president biden is
doing is leading
to get us from here to there what's
happening here today
is a huge step forward to get us from
here to there
by setting these targets by getting
nations invested by getting
leaders to say publicly we have to do
this you begin to get a foothold
on on holding them accountable and on
moving forward and getting it done
is it enough no but it's the best we can
do today
and prove we can begin to move and get
the technologies and
find the easier path and then hopefully
get the job done and i really believe
that
i think we will get the job done as
president biden said today
because of our capacity for innovation
and research and development and
producing great products in the future
and meeting big challenges
and we've always done that and i think
americans are really anxious to do
something like that
that's why i'm here doing this folks and
not you know
in the private sector or retired and
doing something is because i believe
this moment is the moment heading to
glasgow
where we need to get on track as i said
to you earlier
over 50 percent of global gdp
agreed here today that
they're going for 1.5 degrees and what
they're doing will get them on track to
do it
so if we're on track to do it that's
pretty darn good
right even though we know we need to
move faster and we're not as a planet
as a group of countries where we need to
be it's probably a good note to end on
thank you thank you so that's john kerry
the son of actor jim carrey a lot of
people don't know that
um completely untrue okay here now the
press briefing will begin
okay um see how it was so great to work
for him
several times over um okay a couple
i think i just have one or two more
items for you at the top just one more
uh as you saw this morning the latest
unemployment insurance claims
came out they provide a welcome sign
that our economy is slowly healing and
also provide a reminder of the
importance
of both the pandemic programs expended
extended by the american rescue plan
and the 200 million shots we've gotten
into the arms of americans in less than
a hundred
days while these weekly numbers can be
volatile we are encouraged by the fact
that the four-week average is also down
it demonstrates that the
administration's combined efforts are
building confidence in our economy
and that the president's approach can
both create good paying jobs
and address the climate crisis uh with
that
why don't we go home or to you thank you
new york times is reporting that the
next
phase of the americans family plan will
include tax increases on the wealthy to
help
pay for human infrastructure like
education
uh to confirm any of the details uh the
tax increases
are in the often well first let me just
reiterate
the president remains committed to his
uh campaign uh commitment
of not raising taxes for anyone making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year and that will certainly be
reflected in his proposal he makes
next week let me also say that you can
expect that he'll outline
the details of the american family's
plan in his joint session addressed to
congress
next wednesday april 28th but i will
also say that he's
i will be live for that despite how busy
it is around here with the climate
summit uh with his policy team and will
be over the coming days to finalize the
details
of the package including uh the
investments in areas
like child care education and other
areas that are big priorities to him
that we've talked about
as well as the pay force so i can't get
ahead i'm not going to get ahead of
him making final decisions but the
package will be laid out in the speech
next week
it will focus on the areas that we've
outlined child care education historic
investments in those
and as he had did with the american jobs
plan he will also propose a way to pay
for it
and if i could just very quickly uh some
republican lawmakers put out
a slimmer infrastructure plan includes
roads water some broadband some some
things that
the president wants in his plan but
smaller uh any reaction of the plan and
is it do you i see it as a legitimate
starting point again with the package
the president has said from the
beginning that he would welcome any good
faith effort to find
common ground because the only
unacceptable step would be an
inaction we've seen some top line
proposal or top line details as you all
have reported on
we're looking forward to reviewing the
details of the proposal we would expect
the next steps would be a full briefing
and conversations
on a staff level that will continue over
the coming
days and an exchange of ideas from there
and then we'd also expect
i would expect that you should all
expect the president to invite members
to the white house after soon after the
joint session address
but we certainly welcome any good faith
effort and certainly
see this as that but there are a lot of
details to discuss and a lot of
exchanges of ideas to happen over the
coming days go ahead
is president biden going to extend his
call for americans to wear masks
beyond 100 days uh you know peter
he is working and in discussions with
our health and medical experts about
what we need to do
to get the pandemic under control
including
providing clear guidance to the american
public about
what the benefits of are of being
vaccinated including getting into
communities and meeting people where
they are
so i don't have any update on that at
this point in time and so then i guess
maybe this is the same but a little bit
different should the cdc change its
guidance right now that says that
vaccinated americans
should be wearing masks when they're
outdoors when they're outside in public
outside probably should change to
determine and to announce and obviously
we would
follow and abide by their guidance and
check out the recent article from dr
ashish jha on outdoor masks genocide
should we expect president biden in the
course of the next several days perhaps
this weekend
to make any formal announcements
recognizing armenian genocide
i certainly understand the question and
there's a great deal of interest in this
particular topic
uh but i'm not going to get out of the
president and i also don't have anything
else to provide from the podium today
people seem to think that's peter ducey
that's peter alexander trying to reach
this 50 to 52
reduction goal many of the measures that
you've pointed to are ones that are
included
in this broader infrastructure plan if
you can't get this plan passed though
can you still reach that target
well our view is that there are multiple
pathways
for each economic sector of the economy
to
that produces greenhouse gases including
electricity transportation
buildings industry and lands to make
adjustments and changes
some through executive action some
through passing legislation
uh some through this steps as uh gina uh
and our envoy alluded to uh private
sector taking steps
on their own so uh you know just to give
you a couple of
examples um you know we of course have
set a goal to reach 100
uh carbon pollution free electricity by
2035 which can be achieved through
multiple cost-effective pathways
each resulting in meaningful emissions
reductions in this decade
that's a step that is already underway
we can create
good paying jobs and cut emissions and
energy costs for families by supporting
efficiency upgrades that's another area
where
it would have an impact we can reduce
emissions from the transportation sector
by reducing tailpipe emissions
and boosting the efficiency of cars and
trucks something the president has
talked about
that he's committed to do and we can
also invest as you alluded to in a wide
array
of transportation infrastructure but one
of the arguments that we will be making
and continue to make i should say around
the american jobs plan is that these
industries
are we are moving in the direction of
these industries
these are the industries of the future
the big question is whether we are going
to lead that effort
or not or is china going to lead that
effort and the
the meetings today and tomorrow are just
a reminder
uh that the world is moving in this
direction so we either get on board
and lead or we don't and there may be a
disagreement about that
talked a lot obviously about job
creation and the potential for that with
this plan
but can you put this into further
perspective for americans
how does this new reduction target
impact their everyday lives what kind of
changes
can americans really expect to see what
everybody's fishing around for
is stuff like no suvs and you can only
set the ac to 76 in the summer and stuff
like that they're already underway
right there are steps that industries
are already taking
investing in the future of electric
vehicles investing in
the future of electric cars that is
something that
if you talk to many automakers they're
already moving toward that
i think the question here maybe is less
for americans it is for americans in the
sense of what is your government going
to do to help ensure we are on the path
to
uh cr to make this a job creating
opportunity
for the american people you know how are
we going to
prepare and invest in industries now so
that your children and your
grandchildren
have opportunities in these industries
that are growing
but this is already where the private
sector is going
this is already where the jobs are in
the future so what we're really
questioning now is how we can
incentivize
and how we can prepare the economy and
opportunities for the next generation
go ahead thanks jen um you just
mentioned and secretary kerry mentioned
the fact that the market is already
heading towards
electric vehicles there's no turning
back from that it's an unstoppable force
if that's the case why should taxpayers
pay
for 500 000 electronic electric vehicle
charging stations
isn't that something that will get taken
care of by the market
you know i think there's a role for
government to play our view the
presidency is there's a role for
government to play
there's actually an answer she's not
going to give here which is
when you allow there if you want to
build infrastructure
that's for all vehicles then it's better
for the government to be involved in
subsidizing it because then you get the
tesla charging network you've got
chargepoint installing some and some of
them are selling electricity
uh at profit um and uh
there's actually a lot about
specifically the electric chargers is
not a great example
but our view is there's also a role of
the public sector and that this is
uh these are industries that are also
going to
create jobs um and that's part of the
role we can play
you know and i don't think i know
there's been criticism out there
questions about how this is going to
impact
um job creation today right and job
creation in our economy today or some
criticism i should say from
some some republicans in congress that
i've read this morning
seen on the twit on twitter um but you
know the president
is somebody who has created will be the
first in history to create
a million jobs in his first hundred days
in office he's on track
for that in our view um and a lot of
these critics
are the same people who advocated for
the policies of last administration
uh in the last president who oversaw an
economy that lost more jobs than any
president since hubert who herbert
hoover it's kind of quite a name
so join us on the journey we feel clean
jobs can be
good jobs can be create millions of jobs
in the future and that's i think what
we're conveying to the american public i
want to go back to taxes for a moment
because the dow is down about 350 points
on reports that the vitamin
administration is going to propose
doubling essentially the capital gains
rate for
high income americans can you tell us
any more about that plan
and do you have any concerns that that
would discourage
long-term investing well we're still
finalizing what the pay fors look like
um but i will say that the president's
calculation
is that there's a need to modernize our
infrastructure there's a need to
invest in child care there's a need to
invest in
early childhood education and making
the our kids and the workers of the next
generation more competitive
and he should propose a way to pay for
it his view is that that should be on
the backs
that can be on the backs of the
wealthiest americans who can afford it
and corporations and businesses who can
afford it
and his view and the view of our
economic team is that
that won't have a negative impact there
are alternative views or there are
proposals that don't exist yet on how to
pay for it that will be a part of the
discussion but
he stays firm to his commitment to not
raise taxes on americans making
under 400 000 a year and he'll have a
range of proposals on how to pay for his
plans to invest in education and child
care got it and then finally
can you tell us anything about these
reports that the pentagon has been
investigating
suspected directed attent energy attacks
likely by the russians against u.s
troops
well i believe the uh head of uh one
a very high level member of the military
spoke to this and denied those
accusations or
allegations and said there were no uh he
did not have any evidence of those
reports and that's in
some of the stories now so uh
go ahead thanks jen there's been a lot
of talk about innovation
in the private sector but going back to
the public sector um
today uh putting out the international
climate finance plan kind of
piggybacking off
another question when you're giving
money to developing nations
yeah raising that amount of money what
kind of strategy the white house have
for uh dealing with maybe some
opposition in congress there
and also changing within the government
like the administration planning to
spend less on fossil fuels relying more
on green energy
what's your strategy for reaching
republicans in congress for
about the importance of doing this about
how to
you know get them to raise the amount of
money that are going to developing
nations
and the importance of of doing it but
also i mean the wheels of government
sometimes
turn slowly and you're talking about a
lot about the
industry innovation but getting the
government on board
the the federal government congress on
board with the plan
uh well some of this commitment i think
as you're alluding to of the climate
finance announcement
is uh asking congress to appropriate the
1.25 billion
is that what you're talking about for
the green climate fund uh
and we're obviously going to have to
work with congress on that i you know i
think our
collective view here is that um it is
not
uh the united yeah you guys seem as
confused as i am about the question
one of the things that sometimes i find
weird is like this is it starts to
sometimes feel very performative where
like the questions are
not clear and also sometimes of
completely non-newsworthy
uh uh substance and then the answer is
completely non-newsworthy
and somehow everybody's typing furiously
like news is being broken but it's like
nothing's really happening
that when that might be coming up with
with members
or with well certainly we just announced
it today and i expect we'd have
conversations uh soon
uh with members about the importance of
moving this forward one more question
for a colleague yeah are looking for a
reaction to
the apparent pullback of russian troops
along the border of ukraine
do you know if the president is going to
speak with president putin about this
reported plan to move troops away from
that board by may 1st well uh the
president
of course has expressed uh he had a call
with president putin just
last week if i'm remembering the date
the timing correctly and
we've expressed our concerns uh over the
course of the last few weeks about
the buildup of troops and what we had
perceived as aggression on the porter
and conveyed our clear push
in coordination with the global
community to for troops to move back
and to reduce that aggression are we
obviously want to de-escalate
tensions not only in the relationship
but certainly at the border
i don't have any predictions of a call
with president putin to make obviously
he participated in the summit
this morning and they spoke uh just last
week that our national security advisor
spoke with his counterpart earlier this
week
so i would expect the conversations will
happen at that level
for the time being go ahead
um i just want to circle back on russia
again so navalny's health
is continuing to deteriorate and i know
that you had said
along with national security advisor
that you've made clear to russia that
there will be consequences if he dies
but
i'm wondering if there's anything you
could say about what the administration
is
willing to do now or communicating to
the russians now about the need to get
him out before he does die
well to be clear jake sullivan our
national security advisor had a
conversation with his counterpart just a
few days ago
where this was certainly part of the
discussion and conveying
not just the consequences but certainly
our call for and our push for
him to be treated with humanity and also
to be
released and that continues to be a
message that we are conveying
clearly i will say that we have found in
diplomacy that sometimes those
conversations
and the content of them and the level of
them and the number of them
need to happen privately and that is a
more constructive way
to reach our outcome so we are
conducting our strategy through that
prism
is the administration considering any
additional sanctions on perhaps the
oligarchs that navalny had listed prior
to his arrest in january
i'm saying that these are the people
that have sanctioned it would really
kind of change putin's behavior
definitely well as you know because i
know you cover this closely we issued
just earlier in may in march i should
say in coordination with europeans a
number of sanctions
we obviously reserve the right to issue
additional sanctions in the future the
executive order the president signed
just last week gives us authority to do
that on individuals or industries but
obviously our objective here and our
focus and our hope
is that that mr navalny will be treated
with humanity and kept safe and of
course ultimately
be released is there anything you can
say about additional nordstrom 2
sanctions or what the administration is
planning um on designating additional
entities
i don't have anything to predict for you
we continue to believe that is a bad
deal
um and we continue to convey that not
just directly
with a range of counterparts including
the europeans
uh jen can you you mentioned that the
president will
lay out his plans for the american jobs
plan
american families plan sorry thank you
it's a lot to keep track of i know they
sound similar
next week can you give us a sense of
what else he plans to unveil
at his a joint address well uh
he is currently thinking through
which what priorities he wants to focus
on in the joint address
certainly recognizes that this is an
opportunity to speak directly the
american people one of the highest
profile opportunities that
any president has in their first year in
office so core of that will be
him laying out the specifics of the
american family's plan
his commitment to child care to
education
and to delivering on those priorities
and middle class priorities and
ensuring that there's an investment in
economic security from the federal
government
i also expect on his mind are issues
like
police reform health and his commitment
to expanding access to health care
so i expect he'd talk about a range of
issues i will say because i've been
through a few journeys with these
speeches before
that it is a very important speech a
very high profile speech
uh but it is happening around the
hundredth day of his presidency
and it won't represent or touch on the
totality of every issue that's a
priority
uh so it's we are working through uh
what the
uh end content will will have unless you
want to sit through a seven hour speech
which i don't think you do
um just one other question the house
today passed
um a bill to make washington dc the 51st
state
it obviously faces some tough odds in
the senate what's the white house
take on that and and to what extent is
president bike involved in that
going forward well uh president biden
strongly supports d.c
statehood and he doesn't and we will all
our administration
will work with congress to get it passed
we put out a statement of administration
policy
in strong support of h.r 51 just this
morning
his view is that we are the denial of
voting representation in congress and
local self-government to the seven
hundred and
twelve thousand residents of our
nation's capital violates two of our
nation's founding principles
no taxation without representation and
consent of the governed
um and he will continue to advocate uh
for this passing
i will also note an interesting detail i
didn't know until this morning is that
there are a number of members of course
of the of the armed forces uh retired
military who of course live in the
district of columbia and are denied
as a result of having the lack of
statehood
the the rights that many others around
the country have
so there are a number of issues why this
is absolutely the right step and the
president will continue to advocate for
it
okay uh go ahead i wanted to follow up
on the
questions about the climate in ndc sure
um
secretary kerry you you talked about how
important glasgow will be in november
uh when all the countries come together
to meet uh to ratify their ndc's
and given the importance of that meeting
and the importance i think for the
united states to demonstrate
its commitment to action prior to that
how essential is it that
congress passes the administration's
infrastructure plans
with the green energy investments in it
uh given that you're also
up here saying the market will kind of
take care of this
and certainly i'm not trying to apply
that um the market's part of it and the
private sector is part of it and i think
that's an important component of
the very good question of you know how
we ensure
that these changes are ingrained in the
future but there is absolutely a role
for government to play
some through executive action some
through legislation the president wants
to sign the american jobs plan into law
this summer so that gives us ample
time ample room uh between uh that
timeline
and when glasgow will happen but we also
believe that there are a number of
pathways to meeting our goals and
meeting our objectives and we certainly
hope to move forward on a number of them
uh in advance of that uh meeting in
november it sounds like you're saying
that's not the only way that the u.s
can demonstrate its commitment to action
prior to november
correct there are a number of pathways
that include
steps that can be taken within each
sector or steps that can be taken
by the government or local governments
in partnership with a range of sectors
so we see a range of pathways to get to
that uh to
keep moving forward toward that goal
just one other question about your
response to the
initial overtures from republicans on
the infrastructure package you said you
do see that as a good fate ever
it's roughly a quarter of the size top
line number uh
that the administration is proposing
back during that code relief talks
when republicans proposed a number that
was roughly a third of what the
administration wanted
you dismiss them pretty quickly what's
different about
this situation and this policy proposal
uh compared to the relief package where
you seem willing to
take republicans where they are and
maybe a lot more time for well i think
one it's the beginning of a discussion
uh right and
and the next steps will be conversations
at the staff level
conversations between senior members of
our administration members of congress
appropriate committee staff through the
course of next week and then as i noted
the president
will invite members down to the white
house but there are a lot of details to
be discussed
the american rescue plan but we do see
them differently the american rescue
plan
was an emergency package we were trying
to
deal with what we saw continues to be
a emergency fight against a global
pandemic
a situation where 10 million more than
10 million people were out of work
obviously we've seen some progress still
more work to be done
and it the president felt it was
imperative that the size of that package
the scope of that package
met the moment uh and that it happened
quickly
we have a little bit more time uh here
and we are very open to hearing
a range of mechanisms a range of options
for moving this package forward
there could be smaller packages that
pass there could be different mechanisms
for moving things forward
i think something will pass but it's not
going to just be
have your 2 trillion as written i think
there's very very little chance of that
you mentioned uh this 400 000
a year level for um you know nobody's
taxes will be raised above that but
there's been some
some confusion or lack of clarity around
whether that's individuals or
couples or families here we go so what
is that
i've never understood her explanation
individuals
okay so okay uh but i understand
the question and there'll be more
specifics about any of these tactics the
confusion is that by definition
if it's individuals making four hundred
thousand
it could be a couple making eight
hundred thousand but then she said no
it's
previously she said no it's both
households and individuals
i don't totally get how it could be four
hundred thousand for either
a household or individual you know
remotely here from the white house
given everything that happened on
january 6 and given the concerns about
you know the coroner virus why is it
important for him to
you know physically be there well first
you know the president
was in the senate for 36 years and he is
a person who has not just a long history
but a great deal of respect
for the institution of government that
is congress
and he also recognized as recognizes as
we all do
that it's an opportunity to speak to the
people who you will work with in
partnership
to get business done for the american
public but also to speak directly
understands what's going on
for for two months it was why will biden
not do a press conference
even though there's a pandemic now he's
doing then
when are you going to schedule the thing
in the joint session now he's scheduled
it
why is joe biden doing that there's a
pandemic going on why does he think
that's worth him touched on
certainly there were unique factors this
year um you know obviously we always
take into account uh security
uh but in doing this in a way that is a
coveted safe is something that
uh the speaker's office and leaders in
congress are very cognizant of
go ahead all right um two questions
first from someone who can't be here do
you say current virus
yeah and everyone's been vaccinated
right i mean i guess some senators have
refused it but pricing more health
coverage will be part of the american
family's plan proposal
is that accurate and is the president
still committed
to getting those done and discussing
them in his speech next week
well i expect the president as i noted
to talk about the american family's plan
and his joint address as well as a
number of
other issues as you know answered in
response to jeff's question
important to him including health care
the need to put in
place police reforms he's made clear his
commitment to expanding
access to health care it's why he opened
a special enrollment period during this
pandemic
we're excited by the progress we've made
more than 500 000 americans have signed
up for coverage since the president was
inaugurated
it's why he put into the american rescue
plan subsidies to make it
more cost effective for many americans
and of course the president's number one
priority has been tackling the greatest
health crisis our country has faced
in generations and just a reminder again
uh
this is a speech it will it is an
important moment
is an opportunity to allow his agenda
but it will not uh represent the
totality of every proposal
he wants to achieve during the course of
his presidency it is also still being
finalized
and the president will do some thinking
work himself on it over the coming days
on a very different note obviously that
the president played
golf at the weekend there's nothing else
you can tell us about um
how he spends his uh evenings and
weekends is he
is he reading books is he listening to
music is he is he watching movies
he's watching the original batman look
at when the president
is very close with his family not just
dr biden of course
but his grandchildren and he has the
opportunity to see them
at times over the weekend and uh also
see uh
his uh kids um and that's important to
him an important way of how
he spends time uh like many americans of
course he enjoys movies and
he has two dogs he loves and uh you know
i would say
um you know i i think he he likes to
spend time with family and loved ones
and take a moment to take a breath
just like most people across the country
do when he has the limited amount of
free time you have as leader of the free
world go ahead george yeah
biden's really good at the original sim
city you should see what he's building
now been vaccinated especially those who
come in contact with the president
uh it's been a priority george i'll have
to get back to you on the specific
numbers and we've tried to be quite
transparent about that and i'm happy to
do that it's been a priority of course
to
ensure that the white house staff
especially those who have close
contact with the president are
vaccinated but every member of the white
house staff as you well know from
covering
this place i i don't think that would be
accurate at this point in time but we'll
check on the numbers
i will just reiterate or restate that we
also take a number of precautions
including of course wearing n95 masks
when we are in meetings we have very
limited meetings there's a very limited
footprint in the white house we have
also
a number of staff who are working from
home still who would normally be working
on the complex
so um but we're working to vaccinate
staff i'll see if we can get an updated
number to you and others who are
interested in acknowledging that the
white house is not a normal
workspace what what are you looking for
that would allow you to make the
decision that
the president doesn't have to wear a
mask when he's around people who've been
tested
good question very good respect just
like all of you
and like many americans across the
country we're going to wait for the
health and medical experts to
provide guidance on when it is safe to
do exactly that
go ahead in the back thank you jim um
two uh climate
uh stomach questions sure um secretary
kerry yesterday
he said without china at the table
there's
simply no way to resolve the climate
crisis
how will the u.s work with china in the
field of climate
well um secretary kerry has already had
discussions and i expect we'll have i
was talking to him right before we came
out here
we'll have follow-up questions after
president xi's
remarks this morning our follow-up
conversations uh
and there's no question that china
has an important role to play in working
with the global community to
help reduce greenhouse gas emissions
address our climate crisis
that was the case when the paris climate
agreement was signed five years ago and
continues to be the case today
and also the credibility issue market
matters but government matters too
can you guarantee the united states can
follow through
its commitment until 2030.
that's absolutely what our commitment is
is to
not just lay out goals but to take steps
to achieve it
and we have a number of pathways to get
there the president has identified
the climate as a one of the four crises
facing his
presidency and the fact that we are
hosting a global climate summit
under 100 days of his presidency
certainly speaks to how important it is
go ahead what administration
in the office in 2030 the u.s will carry
out its uh
commitment well again i think as my uh
my colleagues here uh elusive spoke to
uh this is where the private sector is
going this is where government is going
uh this is uh these are industries that
are going to create jobs in the future
and we certainly have every expectation
and hope that future administrations
will deliver on the
groundwork we uh do over the next
several years
thank you jen i have a couple of
questions if i may one on
today's the first anniversary of the
murder disappearance of the soldier
vanessa vienne of fort hood texas a
family is still asking they held a press
conference today
asking this biden administration for
justice they want to meet with the
president
is the president aware of the case and
would he be willing to meet with the
family
he's certainly aware of the case as we
all are and know that
the family has been heartbroken i didn't
see the press conference this morning
but have certainly followed the case
myself i don't have any um planned
meetings or commitments to to read out
from here
and then on tuesday when the hispanic
caucus was here they said that the
president committed to putting together
a sort of a task force
on an emergency basis to send to the
border when their surges
of migrants coming in is this something
that the president would work on right
away could we
see such a task force go to the border
in the next few months
i'd have to check on what the specifics
of that are i mean we have already sent
dart teams to some of these countries in
the region
to help address and provide additional
humanitarian assistance i don't know if
there was a reference to that
we've also worked with a number of
countries in central america to
help increase personnel and and uh
resources uh at the border to reduce the
influx uh or movement of migrants to our
own border
uh but i'd have to check on what the
specifics of that actually are
and the last one on the climate summit
today do you have any idea why
the mexican young lady who spoke she's a
batista came in before she was supposed
to why she was moved up on the agenda
today
i'd have to check on her schedule i
don't i don't know why things sometimes
things move in the schedule as you saw
this morning
there was an enormous herculean
technological effort underway here and
sometimes there are movements in
schedule because of that but we're happy
to check on that for you too
great thanks everyone thanks for being
so patient in your seats i should have
brought snacks today you know
all right next tomorrow okay absolutely
okay
covered safe a little bit a little snack
bag for everyone
all right everybody having a good time
there clearly um okay good
so we know i know i will be live on
wednesday with that joint address
and i think tomorrow joe biden has a
pretty
uh big day i may be streaming
something that he's doing tomorrow now i
don't remember i saw a full week
kind of preview of his day now i don't
remember what is tomorrow
we also have some technical elements
that are going to be up updated
between the finalization of the friday
show and the monday show
so we'll be squeezing that in at some
point and that's going to do it for me
today thanks for joining me and i'll see
everybody very soon